[Music]
hey man it's me Kevin Smith and I'm here
to recap I don't review things
the rise of Skywalker Star Wars :
the rise of Skywalker at the end of the
Star Wars saga there's gonna be long
kids so settle in and stuff first off
don't forget before I start talking
about that the Jay and Silent Bob reboot
Roadshow tour goes back on the road on
January 10th in Oakland that's right
Oakland California the Bay Area show man
come on down tickets at reboot Roadshow
com Olympia Seattle Spokane
well Seattle where did Olympia Spokane
Edmonton Medicine Hat we're coming your
way tickets at reboot Roadshow dot-com
that tour sponsored by the good folks at
audible will be an add later on in this
review the good folks at audible Jersey
born and based audible man yeah they're
our sponsor for our tour go figure
because when you think of audiobooks
you'd think of Jay and Silent Bob
alright man let's talk about rise of
Skywalker I'm in this movie I'll spoil
it for you man I don't have a big role I
have a little walk on they get barely a
cameo walk-on thing but I'm in a Star
Wars movie so that makes me obviously
not very objective and stuff but I wrote
down everything I thought about the
movie and we're ready to go through it
man if you're ready to do this with me
let's fix that hat one last time because
we're gonna dive in kids all right
here we go Rhys and Skywalker these are
the things I this is what I bought is
what I thought first Star Wars movie
that opens with a montage instead of a
scene man like you know think about Star
Wars
you know the crawl happens and then they
pan down to the war in space you see
little tentative and then you see the
start destroyer and boom were into the
movie we're into a scene Empire Strikes
Back crawl probox we're empire sending
out probes what one goes to Hoth Return
of the Jedi
crawl come down I think it's r2d2 c-3po
going to see Java or something like that
or no it's the Emperor or Darth Vader
showing up for on the Death Star so
we're in space boom right into a scene
Rises Skywalker basically opens and we
see the crawl and it goes into a montage
for the first time ever we dive into a
montage the opening of the Star Wars
movie and if you're a KY lover or holy
[ __ ] it's just Adam driver murder porn
killing the [ __ ] out of people and stuff
he's looking for a little an oscillation
overthruster that he's gonna stick in
his ships gonna take him the Emperor man
so kylo gets the oscillation
overthruster jams it into his flux
capacitor it flies off 2x akahl which is
a planet where the Sith live man a bunch
of SIF budget shipbuilding SIF man it's
like the New Castle of the Star Wars
universe cuz they just built a bunch of
[ __ ] giant ships and stuff he goes
off 2x ago where the 80s are waiting man
because in the 80s we had the Emperor
and we also had him in the arts as well
in the late 90s that's right man the
Emperor survived the the Death Star
attack in Return of the Jedi and he's
gonna pull the strings this whole time
there you go man it's the Emperor they
ran out of characters to bring back man
Luke Han Leia look they brought
everybody back to like who's left ah the
Emperor and the Emperor came back as
well so the Emperor's you big bad now
anyone who saw the second Death Star get
blown to [ __ ] up or turn the Jedi nose
the odds of surviving the explosion are
c-3po 2-1 but here's why I'm okay with
the undying Palpatine while I'm okay
that he's still there man SIF believe
eternal life is power but Jedi know that
the body's got to go to reach that level
of power it's that simple like remember
Ben Kenobi's if you strike me down I
should become more powerful than you
could possibly imagine the SIF can only
imagine like I'm alive for a hundred
years even though I shouldn't be an over
when I [ __ ] know is dead that's
idea power and stuff they cling to life
while the Jedi know that death is the
door also man [ __ ] in a universe
where Princess Leia did the moonwalk you
know in the last movie Carrie Coppins
did if she could do that I buy that the
emperor survived that trip from the
exploding Death Star to éxito the
Emperor's got busted fingers and a
massive fleet or at least lots of ships
who no [ __ ] can fly and man all these
ships that's why I want to know man I
know the first order is big but this is
like a Costco Costco approach to
shipbuilding it's just not effective men
later on we find out there is no Death
Star to blow up thank God because what
they do is they got a fleet of
stardestroyers and each one of them has
planet killing technology so it's like a
fleet of Death Star's [ __ ] the Death
Star look at this [ __ ] trial size for
your convenience and stuff so they could
just go out and [ __ ] up you blow up a
planet with a ship they don't even need
that giant they'll need Starkiller base
they don't need anything man
it's nice carry over from last jet I
remember they were attacking the base
and last jet I got this [ __ ] cannon
man it's like they've got all the power
of a Death Star [ __ ] beam and [ __ ]
and you're like holy [ __ ] they
miniaturized it and now they just put it
on the ships nice carry over from last
Jedi as Skywalker okay
like Palpatine he says man Ray's not who
you think she is
kylo asks who is she and she's not a
nobody
cuz this fanservice man [ __ ] him so
she's related to somebody big this whole
episode is about no no everything's what
you thought it was so uh she's she's
she's gonna be related to somebody cut
to Chewie
he's playing chess against Finn and Poe
on a falcon a JJ cocktail of the old and
new if you will this moment gives us one
of the best lines of the movie from
Oscar Isaac where Chili's match they're
like you're cheating guard look you're
two uh we know you're 250 years old of
course you're better than us that made
me laugh very very hard they're going to
reckon order with
a spy who looks like the Blue Devil from
DC Comics and stuff and it gives them
some more secret plans these movies are
all about two secret plans and then he
tells a win the wall and then shuts a
door and [ __ ] then since it's Star Wars
they do some warn with spaceships man
[ __ ] pew pew pew
the new light the new thing is
Lightspeed skipping every new thing in
the movie has a kind of first draft name
so they're like they're like what do we
do skip around Lightspeed it's called
Lightspeed skipping the like we have to
find this imperial device that finds the
way to ex ago it's called a wave finder
we are sinking in the these fields they
are called the sinking fields so you
know one more draft and maybe we could
come up something else but anyway those
are the names first draft names as we
found Rayman who we probably should have
cut to after kylo he goes who is she
you know the Emperor's like she's uh
there's she's bored at what she thinks
she is and he's like who is she
they don't cut to Rey that cut to Chile
and and and Poe and Finn playing chess
this is an editor thing man so anyway
they finally come to ret and she flying
with with moon rocks man for lunar
modules as we call them when we sell
them for Jay and Silent Bob weed man
like our own brand of weeds new genstat
even berserker available or baron um at
any fine steak were Wheatley weed legal
weed is sold um they uh let's see ray is
trying to hear the voices of all the
Jedi in the past by saying be with me
that's what she's saying while she
bounced and rocks her Jedi Master is
general Leia Organa or to those of us
who grew up with the moves Princess Leia
who you know it's now when kids watch
this they probably like years from now
when you watch his movie audiences won't
know that Carrie Fisher sadly passed
away before this movie was made so
they'll never know but we do so it's
it's an odd moment where you see her and
you're like oh ho but it's welcome it's
welcome and uncanny at the same time I
still feel like it would have been
better had Princess Leia been the the
in the chair the whole dough maneuver
that would have been a glorious ending
could you imagine like that was the
ending to Princess Leia's story that in
the last movie so this movie where you
know she first time we met her she's
like this Wars everything to me and
she's trying to get a little droid to
get some help help me well we won't
Kenobi to r2 and stuff that her whole
life was about you know fighting the
Empire and stuff and then with the
resistance and and the first order she
was back at it like that would have been
cool but I mean this is a fanfiction
we're not gonna sit here and rewrite the
movies but it would've been cool if she
was in the chair of pure she did that
Lightspeed move it's tough but in any
event we get her back for the third
movie and they made her Jedi Master
which is very very cool
Rey is training with that little ball
that luke trained with in Star Wars
which she breaks by the way no
respectful past and kylo Ren takes over
for a minute man he comes in with that
mind meld [ __ ] like you know they
started in the last movie now he's doing
this thing man he's uh he's he's got his
mask in a box man Darth Vader berta mask
which comes out of a special box that I
hope Sideshow Collectibles makes because
I want my own special little box with a
crusty old Darth Vader mask and whatnot
but he can like they got that connection
so he can like talk to her and she could
be like I hate you and he's just like
you should join me and [ __ ] like that
Finn Poe and Chewie return to the
resistance base where they reunite with
Rey and this is gonna be the theme of
the whole movie is like you know these
cats you're gonna enjoy these cats
together because we want to keep them
together I guess people could play and
they weren't together too much in the
last movie we meet Admiral Ackbar's son
jr. Admiral Ackbar died last year that
one of the hobbits from Lord of the
Rings is there Dominic Monaghan who is
in JJ's lost so it makes sense but it's
jardín for a minute because you're like
wait a second which trilogy and watch it
I put it in the wrong movie
where's Gandalf the secret plans are
about Palpatine and the big fleet that
the guy was like we in no walk and it's
called the final order now they're
calling the you know this will be the
final or they were the first order with
all these ships being able to kill
planets with each star to store they'll
call it they rebrand as
the final order man we meet Rose Tico
again for like a minute and 20 seconds
of the whole movie man big character in
the last movie not she says I ain't
going with you guys like lupus in the
Bad News Bears and breaking training she
does she doesn't go on the adventure
this time so that puts Rey and Finn and
Poe together with chewing c-3po bb-8
which that's what everyone wanted from
you know that's what they felt was
missing from last chat but it feels
weird like it feels like you know later
on they meet a new character a Jana
who's fine wonderful character but at
the same time you're like couldn't Rose
have done that stuff and dominic
monaghan I want to take anything away
from him but all of his lines you like
come Rose is right there can she say
this so Kelly Marie Tran doesn't get a
lot of screen time which kind of bummer
what JJ missed from last Jedi
it looks like was kylos Maseo kylo has
the guy put it back together with some
66 Batmobile red piping man the space
equivalent of duct tape all over his
helmet he reunites with the knights of
brent and they give him blue devils head
man when the wall and they cut his head
off i guess the movie usually cuts off
hands now they're cutting off heads man
all bets are off
for this story's movie Carlo has to
choke a [ __ ] in the boardroom while ray
and Coe go to another desert planet
Poisson I think it's called where
they're having one of those Matrix dance
parties you know where everyone's like
where you're like where did this come
from so I'm getting over a cold thin Poe
and Cole get rescued by Lando but this
is after a little girl gives ray a
necklace and asked ray what's for your
last name she goes what's your name
she's armed right and she said what ray
what and you know Ray's like I don't
know like she you know she can't [ __ ]
that's whole thing I'll know who I am
but it's so weird in this movie more so
than any other movie everyone keeps
asking for people's last names like that
suddenly matters stuff so like every
other Star Wars movie she could have
been like I'm ray people all right let's
go
god forbid this little kid giving out
necklaces ever michio des you know like
what's your last name he's like oh no
baby
um but not you but maybe my first name
is baby maybe my last names Yoda I don't
know
so in any event it's it's there's a
little moment there Finn Poe and Co they
well first of all she puts on this
necklace then she has one of those
conversations with kylo Ren meat
snatches he reaches in he snatches the
necklace from her reality to his reality
and stuff and suddenly that's a new
thing you're seeing in a Star Wars movie
where you can use the Force to [ __ ]
grab [ __ ] could you imagine how helpful
this would be if you were sitting on the
couch and you just wanted something out
of the fridge and you were like you just
grabbed it from the [ __ ] fridge but
the power of the force and [ __ ] perhaps
an abuse of your powers but still
sometimes it's not all about cutting off
the bluedevils head man sometimes you
just want drink blue milk if you will so
they get Finn poco get rescued by Lando
Calrissian that's right man the past is
back those of us who grew up with Lando
are so delighted to see Billy Dee
Williams popping up you know he's
supposed to be a I heard it in canto
bright scenes and last Jedi or whatever
but here is man in a mask and he's like
give Leia my love my only complain about
all this you bring back Lando but you
don't bring back Lobot bald guy with the
for the headphones come on where's low
bond you know what I'm saying he left
that dude behind they were tight I was
like Jay and Silent Bob type change saw
Bob reamer Roadshow tour reboot Roadshow
document um I missed lobizon saying no
complaints after the new trilogy says
hello to the old trilogy they all get on
a skiff and that calls to mind returned
the jedis they're going through the
desert and stuff like that that's when
the stormtroopers start flying they fly
now and the kids land in the
aforementioned sinking fields my man
snapped Wexley Greg Grunberg run II has
a scene with Princess Leia and Rose Tico
before the kids wind up in the sand worm
cave from dune it was a little bit of
dune in this man it's really a big snake
and it took like nine movies but they
finally made a lightsaber flashlight
joke I've been waiting for that since
1977 Oscar eyes it's like ray snaps on
her lightsaber and then Oscar Isaac just
turns on a flashlight right next to me
but if you really want to impress me
tell a fleshlight joking Star Wars there
you go she turns on the flashlight and
then he whips out a flashlight never was
like and he's like in space nobody can
hear you scream ray finds a knife give
me the knife please with sith writing on
it that c-3po cannot translate because
his programming forbids him to speaks if
that's when a giant snake shows up to
kill him all kind of like the rancor
monster and Return of the Jedi
but Rey sees that it's hurt the snakes
hurt and then she heals this big old
trouser snake with the force man like
Wolverine heals it that's new I've never
seen that before that's then there's
this boy band shot of the Knights of Ren
on a hill like just like they're
standing at all posing and [ __ ] because
the [ __ ] drone or helicopter goes
around looks like a Creed video well I
had a whole grin because of the Knights
of Ren I say that falling brazed in this
movie with arms wide open
they eventually captured Chewie after
Finn and Chewie find an old Jedi hunter
ship that knows the location of a
Wayfinder it's a lot of like we got to
go here to do this and here to do this
and here to do this set up like a video
game the series of mini missions then
Big Boss every once in a while ray feels
a disturbance of the force kylo Ren
shows up in his tie fighter his
specially made this my own TIE fighter
looks like Darth Vader's of course and
we do that scene from the first trailer
which he's like but it flips on top of
it well what we didn't see in the
trailer she cuts [ __ ] wing off man my
man crashes it should [ __ ] kill a
lesser person but it won't kill kylo Ren
and then as the transport Chewie takes
off like [ __ ] you know pin is like
right I got Chewie and then she [ __ ]
uses her hand and [ __ ] force grabs
the ship out the air man was pretty dope
but then kylo Ren gets out of his ship
and he starts force grabbing that
[ __ ] the both force grabbing it but then
lightning comes out of Ray's fingers and
blows that ship up and everyone's like
jealous she's like jewelry she thinks
she killed chewy she didn't and then you
know you've seen lightning come out of
her fingers that looks familiar and we
know that the Emperor's in this movie so
mmmm I wonder who raised related to
spoilers chu he's still alive
they think that Chewie got blown up man
they think that the knife the adjunctive
dagger
give me the knife the megiddo daggers I
could [ __ ] kill us 666 kid they think
that got blown up with chewing so they
don't know how to get to the wayfinder
either but that's we'll see in like two
minutes no that's kaseman heroes hide in
an asteroid field from Empire Strikes
Back there's even a ship that chases him
like Boba Fett's ship where ray tells
Poe she thinks she's a sick man because
she had a vision her and Ren sitting on
the Iron Throne and [ __ ]
c-3po says the knife inscription is in
his memory banks they don't need the
[ __ ] knife he's like well I memorized
it and poses well I know a droid cracker
man ohnkoji me who could get that
message from the knife
from your head translate it and stuff
meanwhile bb-8 meets a little droid
named do like Ronnie James Dio and I'm
pretty sure that JJ does that robots
voice so our heroes fly to a snowy
mountain retreat on top of beautiful
Mount Airy Lodge man skg me as posts
stalks the streets of Kojima he sees all
sorts of weird creatures including if
you blink and you miss it movie ruin or
Kevin Smith walking with a robot right
by PO man like Jay and Silent Bob
Annette in the snowy mountain town I got
to be unset and see the movie get made
JJ composing that shot for like an hour
two hours with his giant luma cram is
really beautiful itself you don't get
enough credit for his composition so
anyway then Felicity shows up swearing
giant Boba Fett mask calls ourselves or
Keri Russell
leads the gang through a Star Wars bar
to meet Babu Frick this movie's baby
Yoda
Babu Frick gets the message out Threepio
said but to do that it's going to wipe
three POS memory banks completely for
what I will point out is the second
time in this series they did at the end
of the prequels remember the like wiped
the droids and he was like what so this
ain't the first time but this one's
gonna like you know take them take the
mood to game this means if they wipe
them this time he'll forget
Luke and Leia and Han and all the movies
we love and then the prequel having the
sequels that have since come and stuff
so it's a pretty cool like setup where
it's like you know and and and he's like
I've gotta do this you know I was there
for the shooting the scene where he
looks back and he's just like I'm taking
one last look at my friends who's not at
the game was career-best before mom from
performance moment I felt let me see I'm
reading my thing the SIF message tells
them the wayfinder is on a moon of Endor
and we hear the e word and we're like
yeah I asked you give me that sweet
sweet 80s nonsense and stuff so we're
like he Watts Poe says Endor where the
last war ended
alright there may be races though but uh
that's like the last war was Return of
the Jedi and I'm like yeah [ __ ] it
takes so little to get me happy in this
reference mold [ __ ] man could even been
like hey anyone remember watt oh you
know whatto
[Applause]
memories memories so when they turn out
they do this thing to c-3po get the
message out and then he [ __ ] like it
says that you can find this with
wayfinder in blah blah blah blah blah
tells him where to go to find this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then then they turn him
back on
he's like hello I am c-3po you know
human-cyborg relations
is like he they bring them back to when
we first met him in Star Wars man he
don't know how many of these people have
been hanging out with it's cute they
don't they don't play with it enough
just little bits but like it's kind of
cool idea they wiped him so he's like
who the hell are you people and stuff
and he's all polite to everybody no
longer like you know I've been in this
terrible mission for years he's just
like Hello um let's see
kylo Ren ship shows up is the movie is a
series of rays a place kylo shows up
blah blah he [ __ ] off he chases rays at
a place kylo arrives like they do that
quite a bit so Carlos ship shows up in
racing
Chuy's alive on that ship Zora gives Poe
an imperial challenge coin and that gets
them on to kylo Ren ship and Rey senses
that the dagger is there too so Finn and
Poe go rescue Chewie and kill some
stormtroopers many of whom turn out to
be women this time around there's a lot
of like stop or all [ __ ] like ladies
voices under those storm trooper Abbott
so you know equality in the galaxy but
they're getting killed just as easily so
even though we got lady stormtroopers
now with the men's to storm troopers
none of them shootin very good so gender
doesn't apparently seem to be the
problem with stormtrooper aim they're
just no damn good at right on the other
hand pew pew pew pew pew pew Finn who is
also a stormtrooper I'll point out at
one point pew pew pew
everyone's got perfect damn these
stormtroopers like there they are ch
then they're shooting at the ceiling
[ __ ] dick hey kids I'm proud to brag
that the Jay and Silent Bob reboot
Roadshow tour is sponsored by the fine
folks at Jersey born and based audible
oh yes and tickle your ear balls with an
audiobook at audible and reboot your
reading habits like these guys did check
it out no you can't write stuff like
that you don't even belong in the
audible universe you're a hawk all right
get out of my ear balls
he don't know syntax he don't use
subtext and the worst part he thinks
he's funny man I hate him
[Music]
oh yes if her target who proposed a kick
Isaac kook isin skit skit Skeet Skeet
Scott Scott Kukai is it oh my gosh
I'm listening this audiobook by this
brand new author bro no one's ever heard
of before song Bob and man it feels good
to find new talent not audible man I'm
telling you I'm telling you one day dude
this writer is gonna be super duper
super famous one day nuff said
snoogantay
[Music]
[Music]
you crying kid you listening on those
emotional audio books by audible to you
and what mean old book is making the
baby cry oh you're gonna need a lot more
tissues
a lot more
[Music]
reboot
eating habits with an audiobook at
audible yes for a free 30-day trial go
to audible.com slash reboot smooches
[Music]
Carlo Renza let me see ray sneaks on
Carlo into the kylo ren's room you know
and the reloj shippers are like oh she's
in his room um she sees his vader porn
which is now out of its collector case
and sitting atop a display stand that I
also hope that scishow collectible as
collectibles include when they sell that
[ __ ] mask
kylo does that mind-meld thing and tells
Rey her parents were not junk dealers
like he said in the last movie man
they had way more connection to the Star
Wars saga than Rian Johnson previously
thought and it last Jedi so they fight
and they bust up his little Vader mask
stand at which point kylo ren's like
you're in my [ __ ] room and so Finn
and Poe and Chewie are about to be
executed before they're saved by the spy
who was wait for it
general Hux a big cheery moment when I
was at the premiere so at the premiere
when they reveal it was talks ever was
like ah especially the way he said he's
like I'm the spy it was really fun so
Hawkes you know turns out to be a hero
but you know he's not really a hero like
though he's the finns like why are you
doing this he's like I don't care if you
win I want Carla Wrentham lose like it's
that you don't give a [ __ ] about the
rebels he just can't stand kylo Ren um
he will eventually get killed spoilers
by whitneyhl and I like Pam Richard he
grant you some Chow and blows him away
and stuff where she grants character
maybe force-sensitive I don't know they
said that in some of the the comic books
her books outside of the movie that
maybe he was cuz he references at one
point well he's like I've worked for you
for a long time you know or something
like that to the Emperor to to uh to
kylo Ren about like you know I've been
around for a minute and stuff they don't
do a lot with them to be honest with you
I guess spoilers blown out of window at
the end that's
let me see kylo Ren shows up on the
shift confront Rey once again you're
here now I'm here and he tells her that
she's Palpatine's granddaughter he's
like I am the grandson of Vader you are
the granddaughter of Palpatine how what
do you think of that
you know [ __ ] there he says we're a
dyad and the force first time that's
ever been introduced to [ __ ] one sent a
bunch of stormtroopers that were
standing around watching this scene like
ever they're just surrounded by
stormtroopers kylo Ren and Rey is he's
just like your dad's the Emperor your
granddad's the Emperor can you imagine
that [ __ ] and all these stormtroopers
are just sitting around like awkward
like do we have to be here for this
should we not shoot somebody um let's
see Rey escapes on the Falcon and this
cool move we're like Falcon shows up she
jumps out [ __ ] spaceport and [ __ ] and
the Falcon spins turns afterburners on
the [ __ ] first order and they all go
flying except acabo ren who [ __ ]
forces himself forward and [ __ ] like
that I thought that was badass they
escaped on the Falcon they head to a
moon in the indoor system where they
find the remains the remnants of the
second Death Star from Return of the
Jedi we all saw in the trailer and Rey
calls this a bad place from an old war
and I'm like nah man this is like the
happiest place of my childhood name and
a Minutemen of memories memories ma'am
in a minute okay the heroes meet she
uses the synth knife magic stiff knife
to figure out where the wayfinder is in
the wreckage man and then she takes a
skiff out to the wreckage heroes meet
Janna who like Finn used to be a
stormtrooper she and a bunch of
stormtroopers mutiny that's a story
she's like they asked us to kill
civilians and we didn't do it we just
all put our guns down and [ __ ] and I'll
be honest with you you know I didn't
think of this because Finn's like that's
a [ __ ] force you're using that's the
force Erik Carrasco who wrote a lot of
the episodes of Supergirl that I
directed amazing writer he's working
with me on masters the universe right
now he said all I had to do is go one
more line because you know Finn you know
she Janney goes we just put all of us
put our
down we don't know why or instead of
saying we don't know why we just all put
our guns down and Eric was like then
Finn could have been like why'd you do
that and then she could Jana could have
been like because we heard of you like
uh I get [ __ ] chills just saying it
out loud like how amazing with that
event she was like you have inspired
like while your [ __ ] movies have been
going on in the background you inspired
a bunch of stormtroopers [ __ ] this noise
like you're the star war man like it
would have been cool so they didn't do
that but still it's kind of nice notion
and Finn and and Janna or like hey we
were both conscripted kids man is nuts
and then he starts telling her about the
force but I like Derrick's version
better anyway enough fanfiction writing
we talked about the movie we got at the
Deathstar wreckage rate climbs around
like the scavenger she used to be and we
saw in the first movie man she finds the
way find her but then she goes into this
tunnel and then fights ass it version
herself like when Luke fought like Darth
Vader and the tree in Empire Strikes
Back they [ __ ] mask comes off and you
see Luke underneath and [ __ ] so it's one
of those dream sequences and things and
she sees herself as a Sith the [ __ ]
switchblade lightsaber and [ __ ] and she
got like SIF teeth and [ __ ] looks real
cool umm and then she comes running out
of that fight and she runs into kylo Ren
again and he takes her wayfinder and
he's like oh you want this the only way
you're gonna exit is with me and he
breaks it and [ __ ] and that's when the
fight begins the fight that's in the
trailer where they're fighting on top of
the wreckage of the Death Star in the
waves I still can't figure out how they
did it umm I work in film I'm not saying
I'm a good filmmaker but I work in film
so I know like the pieces that go
together and I'm like that's astounding
that's a seamless the CG sequence
because I couldn't tell where they began
and the water ended and stuff like that
and they were getting wet and stuff like
they didn't take them out into the ocean
to fight kids I'll tell you that much
so it's pretty impressive beautiful
sequence one of the most beautiful
lightsaber fights we've ever seen in any
of the Star Wars movies very epic - back
at the resistance base Leah Leah Leah
Princess Leia lays down general Leia
Organa sorry I don't take anything away
but to me she'll always be Princess Leia
that's how I met her Princess Leia
down and she tries to reach kylo Ren man
in mask untick and Maz is telling it's
like she's the only one who could reach
us some now I I don't know why she
didn't try this years ago but just as
Carlo Carlo and Ray are fighting and
kylo gets the upper hand he's about to
like come down and kill ray suddenly he
hears his mother's voice and he freezes
and he drops his lightsaber and then
rape she grabs it turns it on yeah just
stabs that [ __ ] right in the gut
man for which I was like good yeah Han
Solo kill him piece of [ __ ] he drops
down to his knees like I can't believe I
got [ __ ] beat because my mom called
me [ __ ] goddamn it and ray feels Leia
died that's what happens and she's like
Leia and then she feels guilty that
she'd [ __ ] killed Laius son I guess
cuz then she uses some of that magic
Wolverine healing mr. Miyagi you know
force finger [ __ ] to heal heal been well
kylo Ren and he's all like the [ __ ] and
she's like I wanted to take your hand
Ben's hand but you know her British
accents play better than mine and then
she flies the [ __ ] away and kylo ren's
ship and food leaves him they're like I
beat you and I took your ship [ __ ] you
emo little [ __ ] princess general Leia
Organa dies in in the movies we lost
Carrie while back but in these movies
that is how Princess Leia goes out the
princess that we met help me obi-wan
Kenobi you're my only hope
back in 1977 her journey ends with her
casting their self across the galaxy to
reach her son and that takes all of her
energy and she passes now you know
they're writing within a box they could
only use the footage that they had if
they were gonna use it involved they can
only use footage that they had leftover
of Carrie from force awakens and perhaps
last Jedi so they had to kind of write
around what they you know were able to
work with and stuff but this is what I
really loved about it
Leia dies holding Hans metal which comes
into play later on as well
this is why I love that in their
continuity Leia and Han you know we're a
couple they got together they have kid
Ben solo they spent years together and
stuff like that but what that moment
says is that when she thinks of Han Solo
I'm gonna get emotional doing this
that's the Han Solo she thinks of not
the guy who gave her the kid she wasn't
holding the picture of him holding like
Ben solo she holding that [ __ ] medal
because she is a rebel through and
[ __ ] through her whole life was about
fighting these [ __ ] and their tyranny
and first is the Empire and this of the
[ __ ] first order [ __ ] so him coming
back in Star Wars like when they were
about of their swear itz I feel stupid
but I'm gonna get emotional for this
when they were absolutely at their loves
and they're about to be [ __ ] killed
by the Empire and like you know she's
like what did I do all this for like
we're gonna [ __ ] die and they're
gonna run the world the gallic Steve
[ __ ] just when they think everything
she was like it's all a [ __ ] overhaul
for not the guy least likely the
[ __ ] pirate who was like
where's my money
shows up and [ __ ] help save the day
now we all know that as Star Wars like a
[ __ ] Han and Chewie showed up at the
last minute and helped you know you're
clear kid laws [ __ ] go so we were
all happy cuz like yeah the third act of
the movie but could you imagine what it
felt like for Princess Leia was just
like we're [ __ ] it was all for nothing
I led these people into a [ __ ]
suicide mission and we're all gonna die
and she's reserved resigned to dying
resigned to a [ __ ] world in which the
Empire wins and then suddenly this
[ __ ] guy comes out of nowhere comes
back and does the thing least likely
that's when she [ __ ] falls in love
with Han Solo [ __ ] it ain't an
empire she drags back when they kiss and
that was the moment in her whole life
that's what she loved about that man the
most like you the guy [ __ ] least
likely you saved our asses and like not
only just saved my life but she seems
like God person doesn't care about her
life as much as like you
saved the movement that's all that ever
mattered to me was this movement was the
rebellion so I loved it I loved that she
was clutching his metal when she died
and told the story that maybe I filled
in the blanks I [ __ ] loved it man
sorry
Chewie Poe and Finn come back to find
out Leia is dead and in the biggest
emotional moment of the movie
Chewie drops to his knees and starts
wailing you know at first in his knees
and then on all fours like in this
bereft [ __ ] like all of my friends
are [ __ ] dead like I don't know any
of these people
Luke's gone Hans God and now you're
telling me [ __ ] Princess Leia has
gone to [ __ ] like he's like the rest of
us all [ __ ] like you know it was
really heartbreaking really wonderful
moment that they afforded to then JJ
used all the power of the force to bring
back Harrison Ford man
han Solo confronts been on the wreckage
of the Death Star hear him say hey kid
ah I heard that before they cut to him
like I said the whole audience was like
whoo and I was like [ __ ] applauding
louder than anybody else and then just
as a died I was like [ __ ] yeah JJ and
then they all laughed and stuff I
couldn't believe he pulled it off you
[ __ ] brought Harrison Ford back
Harrison Ford was like I am done with
this [ __ ] so much so kill me in the
first one and he came back not as a
forest ghost man as a memory or
something like that Eric carros go my
writer friend said wouldn't have been
great if Leia like gave her life doing
that
bringing Han to to Ben because she knew
that would turn him or something like
that just one more line or whatever so
folks oh you could interpret it that way
as well let me see Han has it come to
Yoda conversation with with Ben where he
tells him to come home and Ben's like he
repeats his line from force awakens
where he's like I know what I have to do
but I don't know if the strength to do
it
and that he calls his he says dad to Han
Solo cuz he was always called him like
Han Solo in the movies right he goes dad
and then hound solo goes I know come on
man like you can [ __ ] on this movie all
they want but like that's fanservice
beautiful right there that's Han Solo's
I love you he said it to Ben's mother
when she's like I love you cuz I know so
when he's goes dad and he goes I know
that was him Tony loved him that's way
better than if Harrison Ford hits it
Harsin Harrison Ford had said I love you
like in the dialogue um I thought that
was beautiful man really obviously
beautiful to me
sorry getting over a cold so Ben solo
Chuck's away kylo Ren's lightsaber
ladies like [ __ ] this I'm a good boy now
he turns around and Han Solo's gone
which you know sends the messenger I
guess the lesson is like good people are
[ __ ] lonely I don't know but anyway
so he's by himself
great [ __ ] scene great moment every
Star Destroyer in the Sith fleet got
them planet killing weapons so the first
daughter says blow up Cugini man my home
planet so I'm dead in these movies I was
introduced and I'm [ __ ] dead we never
got to explore my backstory unless like
in rogue one I got off the planet just
like you know [ __ ] the guy was like
he don't like you either
I don't like you either and the doctor
and the other [ __ ] dude who Ben
Kenobi cuts his arm off cuz we saw them
on the planet road one and then that
planet got blown up so they might have
got they got off in time cuz they show
up in Star Wars so maybe I got off in
time my character and my robot buddy and
[ __ ] we're just lost in space going
thank Christ we left Cugini when we did
[ __ ] alright Poe talks to lay his body
and he's asking her how he can lead like
she did he's like I ain't good at this
like you you got to tell me how to do
this that's when Lando shows up and he
goes hey man we did it return to the
Jedi and you could do it you just need
friends we had each other it's all about
friendship and stuff and then Finn finds
out from do
some backstory little robot and so they
they're like wait we got a Mac we got a
[ __ ] this little robot has a map to
exit or not map but just knows where it
is exit go instead the little robot do
knew more than like they knew and so
meanwhile we cut to the island of Luke
the island of lost Luke from last Jedi
where Ray is destroying kylo ren's TIE
fighter just like Luke had sank his
x-wing years back we see some porgy and
Ray goes to throw her lightsaber out at
it at the [ __ ] fire she's like I
don't need this [ __ ] anymore she throws
it and then a hand catches it [ __ ]
stops it from going in the flames and
it's cock-knocker man that's right
[ __ ] for the first time ever we get
to meet the force ghost Luke Skywalker
and he throws some shade at last Jedi
when he goes a Jedi's weapon deserves
more respect because she threw it away
and he threw it away in the last movie
and stuff so ray tells you know Luke I'm
a Palpatine and I saw myself on the
throne and I've come to lonely Luke
Island because I'm gonna stop that from
ever happening I'm gonna do what you did
man I'm gonna come here I'm just live
like a hermit that's what Jedi's do
remember Ben Kenobi out and [ __ ]
Tatooine and the sand and [ __ ] and then
you here on the island drinking a milk
from the [ __ ] right off the [ __ ]
teat and then Luke says you know what I
was wrong to be here for that whole
movie say that but he goes uh you know I
shouldn't have been I shouldn't have
done what I did
he goes [ __ ] what's in your blood what's
in your heart man and then he gives her
Leia's old lightsaber who knew that Leia
had a lightsaber I did another and tells
a story about how he trained her to be a
Jedi and there's a flashback the flash
flashback flashback to the young Luke
and Leia training what must be on Endor
after Return the Jedi and then you know
she best some boom dumps him on his ass
and he pulls up his blast helmet his
young Luke she pulls up her blasts
helmets young Leia and Luke said that
Leia had sensed the death of her son at
the end of her Jedi path so she
surrendered her lightsaber at that point
to Luke and said it would be picked up
again by somebody who would finish her
journey this nun I guess the idea is
like she's like I'm not gonna be a Jedi
if I'm a Jedi my kid dies and so she'd
put the lightsaber down as nearest I can
get from that
Brahe finds the wayfinder cuz looks like
look man [ __ ] you got to do this
you're the one and all the Jedi live in
you and blah blah blah and then she goes
I don't even know how to get there and
he goes you got everything you need and
then she goes into the blown-up ship and
she finds the wayfinder that kylo Ren
had used in the very beginning of the
movie and in a nice not the Empire
Strikes Back
forced ghost Luke finally raises the
x-wing from from the water the same one
that you know everyone said in last Jedi
it can't fly it's been in the water for
so long and then he's got no astromech
droid I'm [ __ ] lying of course he
couldn't get off the planet you know the
force [ __ ] he raises the x-wing
out of the water and that's the x-wing
that Rey is gonna take into battle
Luke's [ __ ] x-wing red 5 man man
minute
so we leave Luke behind and that's the
end of Luke Skywalker in this in all of
these movies this his journey was a
little farm boy who looked up the Stars
and was like I want to help [ __ ] sorry
and then his journey he became like the
greatest Jedi the world and you know is
there is he's a force ghost we got to
see the entire almost the entire arc of
his life if you include like the
prequels when he was born you know
there's only like 15 years of Luke we're
missing and I'm sure Disney Plus will
make that series one day but there it is
Mark Hamill you know ends his appearance
at all the Star Wars movies lifting the
next wing out the water well it's not
his final appearance we get one more
bite at the Apple Force Coast later on
but that's a big [ __ ] moment I
thought that was really beautiful okay
wearing Luke's old helmet ray flies 2x
ago
I can't I'm getting way more emotional I
thought I would and at the rebel base
they get plans from eggs go from do but
they don't know how to get there they
know what it's low it's late out but
they don't know how to get there so they
catch a signal from an old ship man they
like what the [ __ ] the like it's Luke
Skywalker's x-wing they cut to Rey if I
could fly it
the helmet you like thin realize it's
right and they do one of those get ready
to fight the Empire montages where
there's a speech and Finn and Poe gurko
lead the resistance into the Battle of X
ax Cole man the last battle of the
entire Star Wars saga no more death
stars just the resistance against a sea
of star destroyers man one of which they
run across on space horses Star
Destroyer could have easily just went
like this listed to the left end or
right they all would have fall off but
they can't they decided you know they're
like we can't get up there with our
attack they're like we don't need
technology and [ __ ] horses space
horses were run across ship it it look
you know choices as the resistance
battles in the air and on the ground Rey
confronts the world's worst [ __ ]
grandpa man he shakes his busted fingers
out or he tells her she's gonna be the
Empress and Rey says she hasn't come to
lead the set Ivan come to lead the Sith
I've come to end them and grandpa tells
Rey you gonna kill me and then I'm gonna
live on and you and the two are gonna
become one and we're gonna be the
Emperor together man you're my family
and he tells her that if she don't do
this if she don't strike him down and
kill him so that they could become one
and become the new emperor and breasts
whatever that he's gonna kill the
[ __ ] fleet he's got the power do it
like all his ships are overcoming the
tiny rebel fleet cuz nobody's coming to
help them they just have this small
resistance fleet and [ __ ] and he's like
they're toast I'm gonna kill them all
unless you do like I say so she's like
she I'll do it I'm gonna save my friends
he's like you want to save your new
[ __ ] friends you'll do this that's
when Ben solo shows up in a sweater he
got at the gap he stopped real quick at
the gap he's like I got it he's goth emo
clothes and put on a comfy sweater that
you would you know so he's going to meet
his the woman he loves
grandfather he wants to look presentable
so he puts on a Gap sweater and [ __ ] and
now he's gone collegiate casual
[ __ ] and thanks to some force
magic ray is gonna like
her back and she's got like the lights
of her hand she's gonna reagent bag like
she's gonna hit you know [ __ ] emperor
palpatine but instead she passes it off
to kylo Ren on the other side you know
the temple and [ __ ] of the ex ago and
he's about to face down the [ __ ]
Knights of Ren and [ __ ] and so he's got
the lightsaber now which is I think was
Princess Leia's lightsaber his mother's
lightsaber and he does the Adam driver
so one really does this real han Solo
Harrison Ford gonna like move and then
she goes in kills every night of Ren
meanwhile a home girl is killing
stormtroopers let you know the Emperor
royal guards around the Emperor and [ __ ]
with her [ __ ] lightsaber then Ben and
red team up to kill Palpatine but he's
way more four-seat than they'll ever be
and he gets a taste of that Wolverine
healing blast them and ship and then he
gets the blow back and he's the oh [ __ ]
my fingers are growing back and he's
like I'm gonna change my plans [ __ ]
being the co-emperor I'm gonna drain you
[ __ ] I'm gonna be a brand new emperor
man yeah I'm gonna suck you dry and
restore myself so in the battle above
Greg Grunberg dies this is the only time
I ever want to see this in the real
world man or it never once see in the
real world but we got to see it like
what would happen if Greg Grunberg died
Snapple actually gets shot out of Scott
blows up [ __ ] pose like now and then
he's like [ __ ] we're gonna lose man
and he gets on his control he's like my
friends I led you wrong like this is
[ __ ] like we're all gonna die I'm so
sorry nobody is coming we're all by
ourselves and [ __ ] and then unlike the
last Jedi where nobody really was coming
and [ __ ] and they were on their own all
of a sudden you know [ __ ] a I was on
your left but you know if I can like
Lando's like don't be sad kid we got
back up and all sudden everybody shows
up every [ __ ] ship in the galaxy
comes to join the fight
including wedge wedge has a little
camera nice shooting Lando
everybody turned out Lea no and that
makes you feel good just like yeah I
[ __ ] the first order and [ __ ]
Palpatine tosses Ben solo into a ditch
he's like this is the end of us
guy walk I suck out whatever the [ __ ]
and he tosses him and he it's hard man
pammi gets his back and then goes down
into the drink and then let me see uh he
opens up the roof and then he [ __ ]
finger bangs the [ __ ] fleet with his
sparkly fingers and [ __ ] starts like
ships are losing their power and Rey is
on the ground like beatin she's staring
up as the first order isn't being well
the the the the resistance is being like
destroyed by the Emperor and [ __ ] and
suddenly she's like be with me and you
know she reaches out and every Jedi who
ever was
we get to hear from from every one of
them who were in the movies not in the
movies
qui-gon Zeo Anakin
he's like you know I bring balance to
the force like I did and you're like is
that what you did Yoda
Luke Leia and then the one that blew my
mind
ahsoka ahsoka Tanna got her [ __ ]
voice you hear her and you're like oh
she's poured a cannon [ __ ]
she's from Clone Wars from the cartoons
and from rebels if you don't know who
was so good you're not a great Star Wars
fan but hearing her hearing her voice
amongst the Jedi powerful [ __ ] and
powerful [ __ ] at least for me as these
movies are you know some people like
they gotta be one thing they gotta be
the other what none some people are mad
and some people don't like ah you just
give me enough moments like that I'm
fine like I'm not looking for classic
literature from these movies I've been
seeing them since I was 7 years old you
know they're fun and they're big and
they mean something to me personally but
like do they don't have to be [ __ ]
perfect man their adventure serials and
[ __ ] and at the end of the day you give
me a nice nice enough moments collection
of moments where I'm like that was great
that was great you know things can sag a
little as far as I'm concerned and
putting a sokka's voice in there just
like Leia hold in that metal [ __ ] like
that was like oh
Luke raising the x-wing and [ __ ] ah like
that's
I think he did it that [ __ ] gets back
here and all the voices gets ray back on
her feet
an old force fingers tries this [ __ ]
with red but she uses Leia's leg saber
to absorb it and [ __ ] she's fighting him
back and he's like I am Aldous if the
Emperor and she's like I am Oh with a
Jedi and she [ __ ] pulls the other
lightsaber Luke's lightsaber into her
hand the boom she's crossing the [ __ ]
lightsaber streams of Luke and Leia's
lightsabers pushing force fingers back
man his death razor like rip the skin
off like Raiders a Lost Ark and [ __ ] and
then BAM he disintegrates and he's
[ __ ] gone until they need him again
some other trilogy she's in the road and
he's like I'm back Po and the resistance
take out all the bad guys in the sky and
that's when a force-sensitive finn feels
Rey like dying and stuff like who she'd
[ __ ] he gave her all mention collapses
but Ben solo crawls from the pit to do
that Wolverine mutant healing factor for
[ __ ] on Rey and brings her back to life
man like the way she brought him back to
life and then all you reloj shippers the
moment we've all been waiting for Ben
and Anne dragged kiss and you're like oh
my God look at that they're gonna have
that traditional happy ending even
though their relationship is very weird
and he was a bad boy for most of these
movies and he killed a lot of [ __ ]
people and all that [ __ ]
including his own father how do you ever
trust this guy but you know these movies
are all about redemption just like Luke
Skywalker saved his dad Darth Vader and
stuff Anakin Skywalker took off the mask
and you saved me my son
she saved Ben and then Ben [ __ ] dies
so they kiss and then he [ __ ] dies so
they they get both sides of the of the
church both sides of the of the aisle
man like the rail o shippers who like I
won't have them to be together they got
their moment they got a kiss and for
those of us who were like evil must be
punished he dies but when he dies he
forced ghosts away and his mom forced
goes away at the same time so you know
he died after he did a good act saved
her life and he redeemed himself and
stuff so he didn't die like the Sith he
died like a Jedi which is kind of nice
um let's see uh a falling star destroyer
passes by Bespin I like that very much I
was like cloud city ma'am annum innum
ennum ember
memories where maybe Lobot saw it that's
his non-existent cameo man he's just
[ __ ] sitting in best been going like
they did it again I wonder what Lando's
up to wicket the Ewok man and his kid I
guess his kid could be his wife that
look like his son popped up to see the
end of the war from Endor man I'm like
looking up seeing a Star Destroyer
fallen down and Wicked's like these
[ __ ] are still fighting [ __ ] we see
the first same-sex sex kiss in Star Wars
movie very brief right before mass gives
Chewie his long overdue medal for
blowing up the Death Star that he never
got 42 years ago man during the big
ceremony at the end of Star Wars and
it's Hans medal so it makes it even
better that was a real nice bit of
fanservice closure right there where I
was like oh finally he gets his medal
I've been bitching about that for years
since I was seven years old Lando meets
Janna who if you read the comic books or
the comics or the books I hear they're
related he's your dad but he didn't say
anything like that he's just where you
from kid she's like I don't know I'm
from this system I don't know he's like
well let's find out and do you think oh
that's gonna be a Disney Plus series but
instead it's just something that was
handled in some other material but
apparently they're related Finn and Poe
and Rey reunite as do the droids come
together all come together all is right
with the galaxy they've beaten these
[ __ ] again and nothing will ever be
wrong in the galaxy from now until the
end of time so the PS is ray flies the
Falcon back to Tatooine and Luke's
boyhood home where he lived with aunt
Beru and uncle Owen she it's all covered
with sand now she takes a little [ __ ]
metal thing and slides down the sand
dune like she did we saw her in force
awakens when we first met her and looks
around and then she has Luke and Leia's
lightsabers and she finds them up and
buries them there which is weird to me
because it's like why would she bury
Leah's lightsaber there she'd Leia
nothing to do with that to me
Luke's makes sense but whatever if they
bury him side by side with her and stand
outside and then she ignites a gold
lightsaber
from her it looks like her own it looks
like she made it from her staff like she
made her own lightsaber and stuff then
an old lady is passing by random I don't
think she's connected to anything she's
on like you know one of them Star Wars
animals and she's like it's been so long
since anyone's been here my friend Erik
Carrasco he was like couldn't that have
been Watto wouldn't that have been made
more sense and wouldn't people have been
like oh [ __ ] but whatever let's not
rewrite what they did
so this old lady is just like you know
there's been nobody there for so long
who are you
and she's like I'm Rey and like every
nosy [ __ ] in the galaxy like
she's like Rey who you know everyone
wants to know everyone's last names all
of a sudden and then racis looks over
and she sees the force ghosts of Luke
Skywalker and Princess Leia general Leia
Organa standing there smiling at her and
stuff and then she looks back to the old
lady and she says race Scott Walker she
picks her name and stuff and it's very
powerful my friend Vincent Pereira saw
the movie and he said then he was the
one that taught me about filming and
stuff and Vinnies take on that was like
he's like look man I like for somebody
who's had issues with his own family
that was a very powerful moment like she
doesn't need that blood she'll build her
own but she has built her own family
non-traditional and stuff I thought oh
that's good that's actually very good
and I saw somebody on Twitter was just
like I hate my family and you know some
bad [ __ ] happened in my life so I
changed my name I took uh somebody
else's name and I totally loved that
moment bla bla so the moments got power
for for some people
then bb-8 rolls into the shot with her
and in background the sons are raising
so it looks like bb-8 there's a circle
on another circle for one second it
looks like bb-8 and then bb-8 and ray
are looking at the twin suns of Tatooine
in that you know very famous Star Wars
shot two of JJ's creations sitting on
the creation of George Lucas and then
you know and credits and then we out
they
it is man that's that Star Wars rise of
Skywalker kids the Star Wars movie that
brings it all to a close I enjoyed the
[ __ ] out of myself I've seen four times
and so I got to go deep and analyze
stuff some stuff I didn't pick up on the
first second even third viewing and
stuff but man I commend JJ and everybody
involved bringing that ship in for a
landing I know some people who like [ __ ]
you he didn't do it right for you he did
it right for me I was I was fine I was
happy
III as you can see I still get emotional
over there [ __ ] so I was there for it
man and I was in it which was one lovely
Kim thank JJ enough he had a rope to me
I had a heart attack like back in
February 2018 and he was like if you
live I'll stick you in the Star Wars
movie and some months later I called
them up or wrote him and I was like I
lived I'm ready to be in that Star Wars
movie and he had me come out and be in
and stuff so obviously I'm biased but
there it is man it was a magical
adventure and for a kid who started all
this 1977 I can't believe we got nine at
one point it wasn't gonna happen then we
got him got all nine chapters man 42
years of my life invested in this stuff
now I'm ready for the Mandalorian I
haven't watched any of it yet because
I've been touring Jay and Silent Bob
reboot reboot Roadshow competition you
arey time to come to a theater near you
watch the movie with me and Jay I saw I
haven't had a chance to watch
Mandalorian but going into the premiere
of rise of Skywalker I ran into Favreau
and Jon Favreau and I was like oh man I
said I ain't seen yet but I heard
nothing good things I said but hey man
who came up with baby Yoda I did I was a
kid out of here I guess my show and he
gave me a coin a Mandalorian challenge
coin and stuff so I that's my next star
as I look forward to diving deep into
that man but for rides of Skywalker and
and the entire Star Wars saga Skywalker
saga if you will nine movies come to
close the book is closed ladies and
gentlemen thanks for sitting through
this very very long review and don't
forget chainsaw bob reboot
or reboot Roadshow calm for tickets
Oakland we're coming to you next the
good folks inaudible give them a listen
they're our sponsor wonderful cats and
the good folks at Disney Rochester Wars
movie and brought you a whole channel
with a bunch of other Star Wars content
on it so I know some people like Disney
thank you for keeping my childhood alive
there it is folks and may the force be
[Music]
you